all right which doesn't belong and why
coach is on the hot seat matt nagia the
bears zach taylor of the bengals cliff
kingsbury the cardinals which doesn't
belong and why i wish that matt nagy uh
was on the hot seat but i don't think he
is i honestly don't i think he doesn't
belong in this group i i think cliff
kingsbury's on the hot seat i think zach
taylor you know you can make the
argument that
they know that they're not supposed to
win right now but it also you could see
the bengals saying okay we have our
franchise quarterback and joe burrow if
they don't win if you get the bengals
were frisky last year if they don't
maybe take a step forward from frisky to
you know decent that would probably be a
sign that like hey he's not working out
matt nagy has a rookie quarterback who
uh was drafted in the first round they
got another shot at it
it doesn't really matter kind of what
the bear as long as justin fields have
come on the field and look terrible
i think he keeps his job no matter what
and cliff kingsbury cliff kingsbury i
think will have a little bit of the heat
this year i really do because they they
put some investment in the defense
deandre hopkins he's supposed to be the
guy who's taking kylo murray to the next
level i think if that entire cardinals
team doesn't take the next step that's
going to be a warm seat for cliff
kingsbury
now a week ago you said that that the
bears quite possibly would fire matt
nagy even though the selection of justin
fields presumably gives him and ryan
pace two more years because the bears
are the bears and they would go ahead
and create total dysfunction by firing
naggy and bringing in a coach who maybe
never would have drafted justin fields
in a million years i'm going to agree
with you on kingsbury i think the seat
under kingsbury is hotter than we
realize the time is now for this team to
make it to the playoffs i really do
think its playoffs are out for kingsbury
they go find someone who will
specifically construct an offense to get
the most out of kyler murray going
forward if it doesn't work this year in
arizona the bears division opponents
vikings packers lions which doesn't
belong and why
i mean the packers don't belong in this
conversation because they've owned the
nfc north and so
i would you know the the vikings lions
and bears are kind of in their own class
and the packers are above it which
stinks to say but it's the truth right
yeah and look i i came of age during the
20-year window between the vince
lombardi packers and the mike holmgren
packers where the packers stunk for most
of that period from 72 to 92 and uh but
but they clearly are the class of that
division 26 and six over the last two
years and i still think that even if
rogers doesn't play they'll find a way
to to make it work matt lafleur is a
better coach than i think people are
giving him credit for veteran
quarterbacks ahead of rookies on the
depth chart andy dalton in chicago cam
newton new england jimmy g in san
francisco which doesn't belong and why
um
i think jimmy g i think jimmy yee
doesn't belong in here because i think
that jimmy g out of that group you want
to throw in the trey lance part where he
is you know everyone kind of admits that
he's
a project and that there's the raw
talent is there but he's gotta they've
gotta work it through i think jimmy g
has a chance that if he plays well he's
going to play the entire year i don't
see any circumstance that andy dalton
plays the entire year and i think it's
pretty unlikely that cam newton plays
the entire year
i'm gonna say cam newton because i think
he's clearly the best of the three the
question is how much gas is still in the
tank i think he's the best of the three
i think he is i think he is i think last
year the covet thing made it seem worse
than it was the late arrival in new
england he had a lot to learn a lot to
process i think he's going to be better
this year now whether he holds off mac
jones is a different issue but i think
of the three quarterbacks if i had to
take one to be the quarterback of my
team it would be cam newton but what
about the year before that he was
injured what about the year before that
was he good was he injured like
he had a show he played through a
shoulder injury in 2018
2019 he had the foot injury that knocked
him out in week two well you got you got
to manage him you can't here's the
problem and i think this is one of the
reasons why he's had so many injuries
when you see the guy he is a giant he
looks indestructible and you give
yourself into the temptation to run him
into the line of scrimmage and and let
him get physically abused on the
football field and guess what he's made
of the same stuff the rest of us are
made of that's how he's had so many
injury issues so there's never been i
think a coaching staff that protects cam
newton from himself
because i think he believes it too
i i'm he is a giant but he still can get
injured like anyone else i'm just
looking at it right now i mean he just
hasn't been the same guy since his mvp
year
he's been
you know
there's a decreasing value of what he's
been but i that's why i push back on the
idea that like oh covet and short mini
camp like maybe there's a chance that
cam newton just isn't good anymore could
that be a possibility they brought him
back though but they brought him back
they wouldn't have brought him back if
they didn't think he was any good they
would not have brought him back i i
remember there was a thought there was a
report at one point they weren't
bringing him back and they brought him
back okay i i i just think that jimmy
garoppolo
uh you know he was he still had a good
year the year they went to the super
bowl he got injured last year that thing
fell apart their roster is still really
good he still has uh george kittle so i
kyle shanahan's system i don't know i
just think jimmy g
could get a little hot here and
especially with a guy like trey lance
who is a project everyone admits that
you could see him playing the entire
year
and
that makes the whole decision
to trade up from 12 to 3 give up two
extra first round picks give up a third
round pick have this month-long mystery
of what are they going to do i still
don't know
what the 49ers are thinking and i think
that this is the aftermath of their
acknowledged failure internally to not
draft patrick mahomes and to not take
tom brady up on his desire to come be
the 49ers quarterback in 2020. all right
one more real quick bears first round
picks which doesn't belong in y mitchell
trubisky kevin white kade mcnoun which
doesn't belong in why ew
uh you know what mitch trubisky doesn't
belong in that group because as much as
everyone makes fun of mitch trubisky
there's a couple of like just facts that
makes him not kevin white or caveman
down david down played you know i don't
know 15 games he started 20 you know
15 to 20. he was in because remember
they did like he was going in a series
here and there so he played let's just
say le definitely less than 30 games for
the bears kevin white played a handful
of games for the bears mitchell risky
played
four seasons they went to the playoffs
twice like he he the problem with mitch
trubisky is he was drafted in front of
patrick mahomes and deshawn watson kevin
white wasn't drafted in front of an
all-time wide receiver kate mcdowell
wasn't drafted in front of an all-time
quarterback like donovan mcnabb was the
second pick in that draft so i it's it's
mitch trubisky as much as everyone piles
on him he should not be in the same
conversation as those other two guys
you make a great point and you get him
in the right system you get him in the
right offense you get him on the right
team with the right coach and there's
still hope that trubisky can turn into
something in the nfl let's take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports